[Musique]
ils partageaient le même rêve devenir
leur propre patron ils ont réussi en
passant par le microcrédit haram
catherine laurent et nadine vous livre
le secret de leur succès corbigny dans
la nièvre son abbaye saint léonard ses
1600 habitants et depuis peu sa
fromagerie
on y retrouve laurent magne son gérant
en pleine séquence nostalgie
trois ans plus tôt il a réalisé son rêve
quitter paris et son poste dans
l'industrie pharmaceutique pour vendre
du fromage sur les marchés donc là j'ai
retrouvé une photo de la remorque
magasin avec lequel j'ai commencé et
c'est amusant meilleur parce que c'est
le feu était puis sur le marché de
caunes où j'ai rencontré ma non
la dit manon gros chèque c'est la
conseillère qui l'a orienté vers le
micro crédit et l'ouverture de la
fromagerie elle m'avait laissé sa carte
je vais rappeler je vais présenter le
projet en moins de cinq semaines le
projet a été monté
moi je partais pas d'une feuille
complètement blanche puisque ça faisait
trois ans que je mendie du fromage à
corbeny donc j'avais une base de
clientèle qui était établie ma mission
était de conquérir une clientèle
supplémentaire
les fidèles de la première heure ne
tarde pas à se montrer
j'ai un enfant embêter tu me ainsi
morceaux plus il a des beaux produits
c'est vrai qu'on se connaissait avec
madame depuis le début de l'activité sur
le marché avant que la décision soit
prise d'ouvrir sa boutique et les autres
clients suivent il y a les gastronomes
avertis
je retrouve le goût de la no l'atome
prochaine mais aussi les doux
provocateurs comme d'hab donc un petit
peu de belloc
voilà je test pour savoir si souvient
moi c'est bien beau mais ils sont tous
différents mais tous convertis
ils fromage réparé des produits quelques
années tiré trois quatre ans donc je
souhaite qu'après qu'on goûte les
produits on est conquis encore et si
tout marche bien pour laurent c'est
avant tout parce qu être son propre
patron lui permet de rester fidèle à ses
valeurs et de proposer à la vente tous
les produits qu'il vit place vivre du
fromage comme d'un seul produit dont la
majorité du commerce
c'est difficile ce qu'il faut c'est de
créer un lieu dans notre activité
donc oui c'est complémentaire et puis
c'est un choix dans la mesure où je
pense que j'aime et quand on ouvre un
commerce à corbigny ça fait partie des
choses on s'autorise largement de faire
ce qu'on aime pour l'instant laurent se
lève chaque matin avec énergie et en
ville dans un coin de sa tête d'autres
projet s'affine déjà ce qui pourrait me
tenter c'est de ce numéro
un qui était pas un numéro 2 quelque
part au sein du parc du morvan ou
peut-être un autre endroit mais
effectivement pourquoi pas créer un
numéro 2 prochainement avec probablement
le soutien de l'adie d'ailleurs d'ici là
laurent ne chôme pas elle s'applique à
donner une autre vitrine à ses fromages
à travers les réseaux sociaux cette fois